c'est
en haut à gauche peut-être ou jusqu'en haut
jusqu'en haut
ok est-ce que
tu voulais voir
d'abord
Ling 1 2 maintenir le trafic 4 milles pour
la montée de
12 Z cap 5,000 sur le
trafic bonsoir 1935 88000
Echo je vois la ligne  en mouvement
ouais ouais
toi ça ouais c'est le sh
principal 9 Del c'est
Inc c'est
en fait ça descend tu le vois tomber
regarde le cratère en bas à
droite ça va ça
tombe la Lune tombe que cette
ligne cette ligne à travers est  c'est comme une
descente en rotation incontrôlable c'est
en haut 9
reany
télécharger allez finir notre
tir 47 maintenir 6 000 6
547 hélicoptère de 5 mil
c'est la première fois que je
le vois ok les gars on descend
Calla ok
stand 47 fling 24 et localisateur à
entretenir  5 000 2 Jo loc 54
filtre B les
fles ouais on peut faire le tour et essayer le
filtre B sur un désolé Ben on veut
retourner au
feu
de
la prochaine
I
je suis désolé ce que j'ai fait une erreur
ok je veux le mettre en pause c'est
quoi l'erreur  non non non je j'avais envie de
soulever un peu le master parce que
les noirs
écrasaient c'est fait
allez c'est le plus dur de garder
le plan long c'est que si tu as un cadrage
tu n'aimes pas tu dois vivre avec
ouais jusqu'à ce que ce soit fini, nous verrons juste,
recommençons, trouvons juste quelque chose
de bien, nous n'avons pas les mêmes lumières,
ça a l'air tellement bizarre, je veux dire, je
ne sais pas si c'est utile mais
bizarre, c'est mieux ouais, nous regardons par-dessus
ici un peu
pour
monter
I TV
739 739
pour ok bien ok ouais
merci moi ralentis
ouais merci
mec de rien
nous l'équipe de tournage la plus polie
de tous les temps
whisky avec
toi essaie juste de maintenir
6 000
6 000 pouvons-nous y aller un peu à droite nous avons
assez de carburant, c'est vrai, tu m'as dit
ouais un peu d'accord et juste pour être
plus proche en traversant tellement d'atmosphère
ouais ouais ça va être
mieux et à deux pas Victor tourne
vers le nord juste sur quelques kilomètres
ici il y a cette autoroute donc tu peux je
peux  mets ça là-dedans ouais ouais ouais ouais vas-y on en a
trois, tu voulais euh sud un
peu pour que tu puisses descendre parce que je vais
devoir restreindre au-dessus de ce TFR juste
devant Ok ouais nous euh nous'  Je vais juste appeler le 15
en haut, d'accord, j'ai une autorisation
pour environ 6
miles, ça a l'air
bien, c'est agréable de voir les voitures bouger, donc
vous comprenez simplement ce que vous pouvez euh
reprendre la navigation du service aéroportuaire4
Victor, êtes-vous large, je sais que je suis dans un  un
petit peu ok fais un grand ok
et
ouais comme
ça
car je comprends bien qu'il
puisse tu zoomes lentement sur
les Flames
mhm mais pas totalement comme à ouais non
donc on ne le fait pas à 70% ouais
ouais comme ça donc on quitte le  camion à
droite ouais, je sais ce que c'est à
droite
B minutes en arrière
Tour à
gauche trop tard le jour pour faire un
g
va
sortir passeng c'est exactement la bonne
chose regarde vers 4 Victory tra 12:00
miles 43 cation 525 en descente je
devrais entrer  il n'y a pas de facteur qui reste utilisé avec leur
indice de perf cation hé, peux-tu dire comme ça pour que je puisse
essayer, allons-y, pouvons-nous essayer de faire
la photo avec le
moment où nous sommes d'ici ouais
pour
essayer de faire un zoom arrière euh je j'ai été
rouler ouais stop stop Le Bu arrête la
lune ouais tu veux que j'arrête je veux un
angle pas d'abattage
ouais si tu peux ça ne prend qu'une seconde nous
avons du carburant pour ça, n'est-ce pas, nous
ne sortons pas si incroyable parce qu'il y a vraiment
cinq feux  dans ce triangle
malheureusement tu ne les vois pas vraiment
mais ouais exactement je j'en vois quatre ouais
mais ouais ce n'est juste pas besoin
de savoir qu'il est là oh je vois ce
cinquième ouais tu vois
le matin ok je
ferme
tu ok je  je pense que c'est suffisant ouais